this video is brought to you by magic
spoon
[Music]
what's up guys michael here given the
general state of things in the live
action hellscape of 2021 it makes sense
that a lot of us would look to the
lighter brighter world of animation for
some wholesome escapism however it seems
like recently our cartoon buddies are
going through it just as badly as we are
whether they're suffering from addiction
issues coping with toxic familial
relationships or navigating systemic
sexism the cartoon characters in our
favorite recent adult animation shows
seem to be dealing with just about every
dark subject under the sun so with the
boundless possibilities which animation
offers why are we gravitating towards
characters who are working through real
life traumatic experiences and in doing
so if we actually found a way to use
adult animation as a kind of therapy
let's talk about it in this wisecrack
edition on why adult animation feels
like therapy spoilers ahead for a bunch
of sad cartoon people slash animals but
before we get into it i'm going to take
a quick break to enjoy a bowl of magic
spoon cereal
[Applause]
now as an adult
eating the cereals i liked as a kid
makes me feel sick and tired which is a
huge bummer because as a kid a big bowl
of cereal was something i loved so much
and it gave me energy throughout the day
now most cereals are just sugar bombs so
as an adult i was bound to crash by
midday if not earlier but today's
sponsor magic spoon is a delicious keto
friendly gluten-free and grain-free
cereal that gives me the boost i need it
tastes like the cereal i loved as a kid
but it doesn't ruin my day as an adult
in fact it makes it better thanks to its
zero grams of sugar 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
140 calorie serving my favorite is
cinnamon but you can get cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter and other great
flavors plus magic spoon drops limited
edition cereals all the time and
sometimes they're so popular they come
back for good like the maple waffle and
cookies and cream varieties if you're
ready to try it for yourself then click
the link below to get some magic spoon
cereal today you can build your very own
variety box and if you use code
wisecrack you can get five dollars off
magic spoon is so confident in their
cereal it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it
they'll refund your money no questions
asked go ahead and click the link below
to get five dollars off or go to
magicspoons.com wisecrack to save five
dollars off your order today and great
news for our viewers in canada in the uk
magic spoon now ships to you too so
try it out find your favorite flavor and
now
back to the show now before we can break
down recent trends in adult animation we
need to take a look at its past contrary
to popular knowledge early animation was
pretty adulty featuring raunchy boozy
and sometimes straight up terrifying
content note we cover this extensively
in our origins of adult animation video
so be sure to check it out with the
rising number of american households
with tvs animation began to be
specifically marketed towards kids with
the occasional family-friendly exception
like the flintstones of course fred and
his prehistoric pals were rarely dealing
with anything quite as heavy as today's
characters well except for that episode
about infertility which was over my
childhood head we're so anxious to have
a baby we take it out on fred and wilma
the show is mostly just about a simple
fella who like to eat bowl and convert
animals into household appliances it's a
living a true everyman what's more the
flintstones is basically just an
animated take on domestic sitcoms like
the honeymooners and even when the
simpsons arrived to shake things up
almost 30 years later this was still the
template they were working from not that
the simpsons never got dark like my
loafers former gophers it was that oh
skin my chauffeurs but a greyhound for
tuxedo would be best the third episode
has homer on the verge of killing
himself after all by the time you read
this
i will be in my watery grave but the
show was more interested in the little
flaws and foibles of lower middle class
life in america than the depths of human
suffering and no matter how somber the
subject matter of any given episode
might be it's still functioned in that
classic sitcom mold you were guaranteed
that everything would be wrapped up
neatly before the end credits rolled
well almost always come on say something
conclusive i'm afraid this is a very
open-ended problem the success of the
simpsons spawned a whole wave of
animated shows designed to appeal to an
older audience with the likes of south
park and family guy making it explicitly
clear that they were not for children
and i do mean explicitly peaches peaches
i'm sorry damn it you could have at
least given me some warning but while
these shows were comfortable wading into
darker waters and the simpsons with
whole episodes dedicated to topics like
sexual harassment child abuse and racism
they largely did so in the name of
subversion and satire this was typically
hilarious and even insightful but which
was unlikely to tell you much about what
it meant to be a real person navigating
any of the subjects they discussed they
were very smart but didn't do much for
audiences looking for sincere emotional
pathos it's the difference between
watching kenny die for the hundredth
time and watching bojack horseman
character sarah lynn die once an
experience from which i will probably
never recover
right cyrillin
sir lynn suffice to say you're likely
not shooting to provoke intense emotions
of say you're also a show that's happy
to have one of your lead characters feed
another kid's parents to him via a bowl
of chili
i made you eat your parents the point of
this kind of adult animation was to use
the looser boundaries of the medium to
go completely balls to the wall putting
things on screen that would either be
physically impossible or extremely
illegal if done by an actual human being
it was about leaning into the chaos to
mind comedy from all the darkest most
[ __ ] up stuff the writers could come
up with and it was okay to laugh at it
all because ultimately
they were just cartoons
right but in more recent years we've
seen more and more shows ask us to
emotionally invest in our animated
friends at a much deeper level adult
animation is still as wild as it's ever
been one glance at rick and morty's
phone munching chair people or tooka and
birdie's turtle horde and neighbor will
tell you that but they've integrated
some of the harshest parts of our
reality into their own colorful worlds
the prime example is bojack horseman
which despite its constant punting and
weird animal antics is basically a whole
show about depression it explores mental
illness in a way that often veers into
the territory of addiction is this like
an a.a thing no i don't need a childhood
trauma
ptsd
and a host of other places where
unhappiness can take root similarly big
mouth's animated middle school hijinks
allow it to dig into the messy parts of
adolescence as well as the psychological
toll that divorce can take on a kid and
rick and morty might go on adventures
through a multiverse full of giant butts
and greasy grandmas but the heart of
their story is usually about self-hatred
despair and broken relationships and
even a show as visually delightful and
formally playful as touka and birdie
still finds a way to deal with painful
subjects like sexual assault chuka i
have to tell you something so whichever
present day adult animated series you're
into it's safe to say that we've come a
long way from the gentle rhythms and
easy resolutions of bedrock and
springfield and that where we are now is
a hell of a lot darker so the big
question is why why would we look
towards places full of talking animals
and shame wizards to explore the harsher
parts of the human experience part of
the appeal might have to do with the
medium of animation animated characters
have an inherent sort of universality
about them in animation genre and
authorship scholar and artist paul wells
summarizes psychoanalyst martin grojin
writing that the animated figure works
as a symbol that transcends materiality
but makes material impact essentially
cartoons can actually be easier for us
to project ourselves onto because
they're not real i mean have you ever
felt more seen by a flesh and blood
human being than you have looking at the
this is fine dog similarly animation
expert professor paul wells has said
that animation itself creates a space
for characters or phenomena to operate
on more symbolic or metaphoric terms and
conditions which invites a greater
degree of possibly highly charged
emotive or abstract interpretation
animation is by nature a bunch of
symbols that we've created to represent
reality
so it kind of makes sense that we'd be
inclined to engage with them on a
metaphorical level even if some of those
symbols are things like sperm monsters
and centaurs animation is also far less
beholden to logic than most other
mainstream entertainment we'll gladly
accept characters surviving things that
should kill them or the entire cities
being flattened and then instantly
rebuilt just so long as everyone
involved is made of ink and on a
different level it's also less beholden
to the dominant logic of our societies
so rick and morty can point out economic
exploitation in a way that would make a
live-action comedy feel like a huge
bummer does he like it it's a metaphor
for capitalism morty what do you think
what's more
being less tethered to reality often
allows animated shows to evoke their
characters feelings and mental states
much more directly something which
bojack horseman was always uncomfortably
great at think about the opening credits
where we watch him float through scenes
from his life in an emotionally detached
haze later we come to understand it's
his primary defense mechanism or
consider the incredible almost wordless
underwater episode where bojack is
forced to navigate a world he doesn't
understand without being able to talk
emphasizing his emotional isolation or
think about the increasingly abstracted
visuals used to portray his emotional
breakdown in season 5 allowing us to
experience the disintegration of reality
right alongside him in one such episode
the full immersive capacity of animation
allows for his co-star and girlfriend
gina's cliche showtune song to read as
dark and menacing complete with dancing
popsicles part of the reason we were
able to get such a rich understanding of
bojack as a character was because the
entire show could be warped to reflect
his interior life and make it visible to
the viewer has anyone ever come back
from this place
bj
there is no place it's just your brain
going through what it feels like it has
to go through and this is true whether
he's running through the washed out
imagery of his youth or watching diane
the only person to ever effectively call
him out on his bull turn into a
terrifying monster of course it goes
without saying that adult animation's
introspective possibilities for
achieving subjectivity also makes it
very good at depicting drug experiences
similar tactics have been employed by a
host of other adult animated shows too
bigmouth was able to make a full-blown
musical spectacle out of a young woman's
first period this reflects how from
jesse's point of view having everyone
know she was on her period felt about as
seismic and humiliating as being
followed by a giant singing tampon in
tooka and birdie quote-unquote reality
is similarly malleable when
gentrification threatens their
neighborhood it's symbolized by a
pervasive moss that creeps into the
bird's apartment building when tooka
brushes fingers with her crush she's so
excited that her bones literally fall
out and birdie has to pick them up but
just what a brush with a crush truly
feels like isn't it and of course
there's the show's deft handling of
birdie's sexual assault when she was 12.
the show's normally chaotic animation
style falls away in favor of a parrot
down color palette and faceless figures
and it's the magic of animation that
lets us truly see the experience from
the victim's perspective there's also
the various outlandish ways the
boondocks found to use japanese anime
style to explore black american trauma
sometimes that means bringing martin
luther king jr back to life to comment
on contemporary black culture something
that might border on sacrilege if
employed in live action and frequently
that means empowering its central
character huey to engage in
gravity-defying fight scenes that in
their outlandishness paradoxically
managed to accurately reflect the full
scope of his inner power and rage when
you take a look around the anything goes
nature of animation actually allows it
to aim directly at the stuff that's the
most real okay so that might explain why
animation is so effective at exploring
the inner lives of its characters but
that still leaves the bigger question
why do we care why do we seem to get so
much value out of watching animated
characters process their pain if you
were to ask ancient greece's biggest
intellectual show-off aristotle he might
tell you that it's all about catharsis
that watching characters undergo tragedy
provides us with a vital release for our
own feelings of sadness fear and anger
and while many parts of these shows may
be symbolic they tend to get very
literal when it comes to darker issues
we might not know what it's like to have
our fiance stolen by a cyborg or our
wife killed by a version of ourselves
from another dimension but we've got
plenty of experience with the other
issues which affect these characters
rick archer and bojack all struggle with
alcohol issues as do about six percent
of american adults and one out of every
nine americans over the age of 65
suffers from the sort of dementia that's
so brutally portrayed in bojack and over
400 000 more americans each year will
sadly be able to relate far too easily
to the experience of sexual assault in
tooka and birdie in their journey
through the darker corners of existence
these shows will almost certainly bump
up on something that either the viewer
or someone in their life has dealt with
making it all powerfully painfully real
but what really makes these animated
shows hit quite so hard it's probably
all the hours we spent staring
square-eyed at cartoons while we were
children and it turns out our parents
were right that all that tv time would
mess us up my bad dad although they
probably just thought it would ruin our
eyes and attention spans not that we
would one day be emotionally ruined by
watching a horseman accidentally
seducing a teenage deer so actually
never mind dad i take it back animated
shows carry an even greater pathos for
those of us who grew up watching them
because they present what wells
describes as the fictionalized notion of
consciousness which if imagined real
both recalls the playful and liberal
apparatus of childhood and makes
concrete the irony and contradiction of
the adult sensibility what that means is
that adult animation occupies a sort of
liminal space that splits the difference
between the fond childhood memories
which the medium recalls and the brutal
adult realities which modern shows
portray so we come to these shows with
all the emotional openness of a sweet
summer child only to be met with the
wall-to-wall adult misery that's on
display and it might even be more than
that because in our softened cartoon
watching state we aren't braced for an
emotional gut punch the way we are
checking out a prestige live action
series over on hbo so when we watch
bojack strangling his co-star while in
the midst of a drug-addled nervous
breakdown or come face to face with the
crushing sadness of woodhouse's death
and archer it can catch us completely
off guard and he had a good long life he
did
for a heroin addict the anything goes
consequence-free antics of our looney
tunes days suddenly gives way to the
absolute reality of what's happening to
the characters on screen and we're
forced to accept that the wounds being
made won't just be erased and replaced
for the next frame they're here to stay
every bit as permanent as the marks we
make in real life of course you can
always just pull a rick sanchez and
reject this sort of therapeutic value
right out of hand i don't think going to
a rented office in a strip mall to
listen to some agent of averageness
explain which words mean which feelings
has ever helped anyone do anything i
think it's helped a lot of people get
comfortable and stop panicking which is
a state of mind we value in the animals
we eat but not something i want for
myself but to do so would surely be
missing a large part of what these shows
have to offer we're in the midst of a
golden age of adult animation thanks to
a bunch of shows with a lot on their
minds and it seems like it's the same
stuff that a lot of us are going through
too so maybe we can work through life's
more painful aspects together with a few
badass action sequences bizarre musical
numbers and outlandish psychics thrown
in to let us have some fun along the way
but what do you guys think why do shows
like bojack horsemen seem to [ __ ] us up
so much more than shows which don't
include asexual axolotls and strip
dancing orcas feel free to play armchair
psychologist down in the comments thanks
as always to our patrons for all your
support and remember to check out our
podcast hit that subscribe button like
your birdie punch and pastry dough and
don't forget to ring that bell and as
always thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you